late last week we reported that gas
prices had hit a whopping
3.73 cents per gallon on average
man those were the good old days you
remember those wonderful old days now
gas is up to four dollars and 17 cents
per gallon that's a 44 cent jump from
last week and a 61 cent spike from a
month ago
one year ago today
after only a month and a half of joe
biden wreaking havoc on the economy gas
averaged just 2.76 cents per gallon
nationally now it's hit an all-time high
so what is joe biden going to do to fix
it
you guessed it absolutely nothing
can't do much right now
russia's responsible
can't do much it's putin's fault
everything is putin's fault the buck
stops with putin
except
gas prices were already spiking under
joe biden well before putin invaded
ukraine
gas has been going up consistently
since just after joe biden was sworn
into office but according to biden that
is purely a coincidence it has nothing
to do
with his energy policies
look let me be clear
about two other points first it's simply
not true that my administration or
policies are holding back domestic
energy production
that's simply not true
it's simply not true okay it's simply
not true that biden canceled the
keystone xl pipeline on his first day in
office it's simply not true that biden
re-entered the anti-fossil fuel paris
agreement on his first day in office
it's simply not true that biden
suspended all new federal gas and oil
leases five days after he was sworn into
office it's simply not true
that biden just a couple weeks ago
indefinitely froze decisions about new
federal oil and gas drilling it's simply
not true even though
i distinctly remember all of those
things happening
so either my memory is failing me and
all those news reports about all those
well-known policy decisions are an
illusion or
joe biden is lying again and gaslighting
us all again trying to distract from his
uninterrupted record of failure by
claiming that putin ate his homework
who are you going to believe joe biden
or your own lying
eyes i'm glad that you liked that clip
if you want more clips ring the bell
subscribe get notifications also what i
would strongly recommend is you go to
your podcast app apple podcast spotify
stitch or google play wherever you get
your podcasts type in the michael
knowles show it's very easy click
subscribe
if you would be so kind maybe leave a
five star review
and we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you